inquiet c'est ce que nous verrons après
la rupture la fusion pendant une heure
et sept minutes françois fillon s'est
employé dans son discours de politique
générale à faire passer pour sienne des
réformes et des orientations politiques
déjà tracée par nicolas sarkozy le
premier ministre a également revendiqué
une entente idyllique avec le président
de la république où il entend ainsi
mettre fin aux critiques de ceux qui le
renvoie à un rôle subalterne morceaux
choisis
réaction catherine démangeât laurenceau
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
aujourd'hui c'était son heure 1h07
précisément pour exister face à nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon avait promis
d'éviter le catalogue le copier coller
des promesses de campagne
et pourtant c'est bien une succession de
réformes qu'il décline avec un impératif
réduire la dette
nous maintiendrons le cap du
désendettement et du retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
nous ramènerons notre dette publique en
deçà de 60% du produit intérieur brut et
nous rétablirons une situation
budgétaire à l'équilibré en 2012
françois fillon se pose en garant de la
rupture sarkozienne même méthode
réformer tous azimuts avec une priorité
l'université
le gouvernement y consacrera 5 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2012
autre mesure phare la construction de
cinq cent mille logements neufs par an
dont 120 mille logements sociaux
éducation logement santé pour financer
les réformes
le premier ministre compte sur une
hausse de la croissance et au chapitre
des institutions il promet de donner à
l'opposition un vrai statut et au
parlement l'ouverture n'est qu'une étape
sous l'autorité du président de la
république je vous propose de poser les
bases d'une démocratie mieux équilibrées
et plus transparentes
une démocratie au sein de laquelle le
pouvoir exécutif agi avec clarté dans
l'unité du couple formé par le chef de
l'état et le premier ministre
mais pour françois hollande ce n'est pas
un scoop mais un homme et un seul qui
est à la manoeuvre
nicolas sarkozy omniprésent omnipotent
omniscient
le chef de l'état décide de tout parle
de tout intervient surtout évoquent tout
et quand et quand il ne le fait pas ça
peut lui arriver
monsieur le premier ce n'est pas vous
qui intervenaient c'est le secrétaire
général de l'elysée qui donne le
calendrier
sans surprise les députés ont voté la
confiance
la session extraordinaire est donc
ouverte dès demain l'assemblée débattra
du traité simplifié adopté au dernier
sommet de bruxelles et sans détour c'est
le